let's jump to this next story from the
postal Millennial FBI Flags slang terms
Chad based red pilled it's over to
Target racially motivated violent
extremists the FBI's domestic terrorism
reference guide on involuntary celibate
violent extremists offer a threat
overview for in cells that aim to
identify them by the slang they use
so uh you thought Biden's 50 Cent Army
was bad yeah you're gonna have a whole
bunch of crackpot cultists getting paid
to promote Democrats now the feds are
going to be targeting you if you say
things like based and that's one of the
reasons your former guest Vivek wants to
eliminate the FBI one of the many
reasons he wants to eliminate the effort
I love that I'm like wow this guy's he's
pretty hardcore you know Ron Paul was
saying that many decades ago he was
saying that 30 years ago and I think
there's individuals even before that at
the very beginning of the FBI they have
a horrible record especially with J.R
Hoover especially with what they did to
JFK what they did to MLK what they did
to Malcolm X the the what they did with
MK Ultra holy cow if you look at this
agency there needs to be some oversight
there needs to be some accountability
there was just a new disclosure
happening with the proud boys trial with
January 6th and it people just found out
that out of the 13 proud boys eight of
them were paid FBI informants five of
them are being prosecuted so so that
that's more federal agents that took
part of January 6th a part of The Proud
boys than the actual proud boys which is
crazy
those are insane numbers and then
they're hiding and and making sure that
they're spying on the defense I mean
what's happening with the January 6 case
is just a notion of what's going to be
happening to everyone unless we we
address this and stop it so this is a
very post-modern notion the idea that
that power is everywhere and you can use
words and they've done so incredibly
they've been incredibly effective at
this you can use words to change the
culture you can use words and I mean
think about that red pill I mean these
are not the n-word they're not even
remotely close to it these are words
that indicate a condition oh you know
from The Matrix but it's not that it's
it's a it's a reference to being part of
a subculture and if the FBI thinks based
or Chad
racially motivated extreme the left uses
base too exactly there are seven words
altogether it was based red pill blue
pilled Normie Chad LARPing and Intel is
that if that's the criteria you're using
WOW
but leftists use LARPing substantially
more than people on the right do to
claim that the right is live-action
role-playing their fantasies this is a
big problem with the FBI's having now is
they're Downstream from social media
from the technology and all this data
can be spoofed like if Facebook wants to
tell the FBI that you said something you
didn't say they can and they can make it
look like you did in the software even
the idea that we live in the United
States and then this is an issue at all
is insane that is another reason why
there's a legitimacy Christ nobody
trusts the institutions anymore it's
because it's a global Community now like
we live in the US but this this Global
governance it's here now we can say like
it's coming but it's here now like it's
the it is one unit government that's
right
so in your face though when you have a
moment in time in history where you say
Chad you're going to be investigated by
the FBI right if you say it online you
say in cell you say right bill you go to
Epstein Island you're on The Client List
of Mr Epstein FBI's like yeah you're
clear you're good don't worry about that
how in the world are we allowing the
Federal Bureau of Investigations that by
the way the doj FBI had an investigation
on Epstein they never released the
findings of that investigation they have
The Client List they have the videos
they have the pictures of very powerful
people doing some very horrible things
I mean if you know if you were on some
dude's Island and then you were asked to
investigate yourself you wouldn't
release the list either that's true good
point very good point there so yeah so
yeah I imagine that's likely the
circumstance I think uh why are we
letting people do this because people
haven't stepped up to build systems that
are resilient to this kind of behavior
so it's going to happen we need systems
that are encrypted where we control
locally our own our own system we need
to be able to govern ourselves locally
um as best as possible when you start
building systems like that that are not
untrackable but challenging to track I
think you're in a better play where the
codes readable the issue is the the FBI
doj have gone after anybody who makes
encrypted Communications I feel like
they're afraid that there's going to be
some sort of Revolt or like revolution
in the states I hadn't heard that I
encrypt everything oh yeah I mean aside
from the fact that they've probably
cracked a whole lot of the encryption
telegram the Russian government has
attacked a cracked telegram they're
investing people who who well let me let
me complain about the Russian war I'll
just ask you something very simple who
do you think has more cyber resources a
private company or a nation-state if
we're talk it obviously it depends on
the nation state right you know I think
Chiquita bananas had a good hold over
what was it uh what countries was it
Nicaragua I don't know I don't think it
was Costa Rica
um but anyway I digress we're talking
about Russia and their military
capabilities in terms of cyber warfare
pretty sure they're gonna have more
resources than Telegram and they're
going to have a capability to either
crack telegram encryption or simply put
go to the people who run it and then say
here's what you're going to do or else
you know maybe the CEO of some company
goes out for his uh pick up his
newspaper in front of his apartment when
a black van pulls up guys throw a bag
over his head throw him in they drive
off nobody knows it happened and then he
wakes up in a dark room and they're like
you're going to give us a back door to
all of your encryption or else and they
go whatever you say and that's exactly
what happened to Lava bit and the
founder of lava bit I I interviewed the
guy it was Edward snowden's email
service that he was using the feds came
to him and says give us everything on
Edward Snowden or else and then he I
believe he printed out a hundred pages
of the password uh in very small font
and then gave it to the FBI legally
complying with them and they had to
manually put in the long password to the
encryption and then when they were doing
that I think he deleted the server shut
the whole company down shut the whole
company down and then and then this is
why you know this is like in China this
is almost exactly what's happening in
China but here we just have a different
face on it and and the more we don't
understand this reality the more we kind
of hinder ourselves because when we look
at Facebook when we look at YouTube when
we look at you know as we found out from
Twitter we're not looking at private
entities and private corporations we're
looking at government hand inside of the
business directing not only who gets to
say whatever whatever they want to say
who gets to see it why they get to see
it who gets promoted who gets demoted
that right there is the power to control
people's minds and that's the power that
they're wielding every single day and
people need to realize it more than ever
this story that came out a few weeks ago
or like a week and a half ago that Elon
Musk said they were qualifiers coded
into the Twitter system that would
identify you as a Democrat a Republican
or a VIP
or Elon Musk which was funny and weird
that he had his own special category of
like this is Elon he's tweeting but they
would label you a Democrat or Republican
like they had that in their system and
people were calling that out how much do
you want to bet that if you had the
Democrat tag yeah that was okay that you
said that thing about those kids when
that guy posts the the picture of the
wood chipper with blood coming out
during the Covington incident I wonder
if he had one of those tags on it he's
okay
so the thing that's been running through
my mind through this conversation is
let's say that somebody who doesn't
listen to you Tunes in Tim
it's so hard to break through to people
when you show stories like this or when
you talk about
scores or when you talk about because
they'll just think you're a conspiracy
theory lab leak conspiracy so how do we
the thing that I've been thinking about
for quite a while is how do we reach
these people like what is it that we can
say or how do we
convey this in a way that makes them
think
I'll put myself in the script we are not
conspiracy theorists when we talk about
this oh this is funny I mean look we we
I use newsguard certification for all
the sources we use
I know news guard's not good I know
they're biased they attacked us and then
put a bunch of lies about timcast.com we
still end up getting a near we end up
getting a near perfect score they they
gave us a strike out of you know out of
like 10 we got one because we quoted
Donald Trump that's it that's all we did
yeah we ran a story Donald Trump said
this they went oh nope nope that's fake
news and I'm like all we're doing is
quoting a guy but I digress the point is
when I try and talk to people who are as
I describe uninitiated I'm not going to
come out right away and start talking
about barisma and Ukraine and all this
really crazy stuff I'll take it really
really light and be like yeah that the
Trump impeachment wasn't that that was
um what was it there's that video of Joe
Biden saying that he was threatening to
withhold congressionally approved Aid
which was illegal or something like that
real light approach and then if they say
what I've I don't know anything about
that I'll be like oh here I'll show you
and then you just pull up a NPR or some
other news source and be like I don't
know read it do you tell me what you
think I I usually take that approach
I'll say here's the story what do you
think yeah I have the opposite approach
I I just go right over the head satanic
child
let's just go there I think different
people have different ways of of you
know of approaching this information but
I think first of all the conversation
needs to be started we're doing well I
agree the conversation starts with the
people who are listening the people who
are taking notes the people who are
studying because you guys need to be
informed more than ever and it it's it's
it's it's the game's rigged on social
media the game's rigged here the game's
rigged everywhere online but it's not in
real life this is why again I'm not just
trying to be a shield here but I've been
a big proponent of t-shirts I've been a
big proponent of people talking to their
family members their friends and I think
that is more imperative than ever of
individuals doing their homework doing
their research and whether it's having a
light-hearted kind of uh approach of
empathy whether it's hitting them over
the head with just the bigger truths
going down the rabbit hole who knows
what will work but I think being uh
Brave and and being able to have those
conversations is the first step that we
need to have but the other thing too is
outside of all of that there's a real
simple way to win it's called voting
with your dollars so shout out to our
friends at Public Square download the
Public Square app they've sponsored the
show before but this is a freebie
because I really do believe in what
they're doing it's an app that shows you
businesses that have taken a pledge to
support American values so you can make
sure you're giving your money to
companies that that believe in the good
and then uh don't buy anything from
Anheuser-Busch and don't donate to your
alma mater please yeah yeah uh Will
Chamberlain like to say I don't know if
he still does I'm assuming he just seize
the endowments yep and that's one of the
things that we're doing at my non-profit
National progress Alliance do not it
should be the easiest ask in the world
don't donate by the way just I
personally don't like the hardcore
approach so I'll ask people I'll say
something like which is true I don't
know if you guys were I don't want to go
down this rabbit hole but I personally
was duped by the hunter Biden laptop
store I thought it was a plant I get I'm
betting you guys didn't I jury's out I
mean I can't wait for facts and improve
roof and I want proof three times before
I start to accept something Luke Luke
probably went completely in the other
direction yeah yeah and then I was
probably in the middle like let's figure
out where this came from yeah so the way
that I try to reach people is I'll say
you know I like I'll put it on myself I
fell for that what were you thinking
about that oh or I and then I'll say
well which is also true I didn't really
know whether or not it was a lab leak
hypothesis but the lab League hypothesis
shoot but all these people said people
who were in Authority people who were
supposed to be trusted I believe them
and I was wrong in other words like I
was wrong maybe they were wrong I was
wrong but what about this like what
about this so if you can undermine their
confidence in things in the past they
can make their own conclusions about
whether or not I think the best thing
you do is be genuine and if you believe
something say you actually believe in
those things and I think living your
life as an example being like hey I
don't do this I don't support this I
don't want my money going towards this I
don't want to spend my time investing in
these really bad people that are
connected to these really awful people
with these chemicals and this thing and
I think and and and again it's all
personable so if you're seeing someone
who's very kind of sensitive who's very
kind of introvert you obviously don't do
my method you obviously use Tim's method
but if you see someone who is is is you
know open-minded someone eager obviously
you just beat him over the head straight
down the rabbit I like this Steel Man
the opposition I kind of take that role
on this show a lot of times people in
the audience think I'm like an idiot but
like I will act as if we are wrong and I
will give you yeah it's it's so
important to do that and it's also so
unfortunate that you have to it's so
unfortunate that woke people will not
have conversations with you they will
not engage in discussions Smart Ones
understand why they can't well a hundred
percent because they they have no it's
such a banker bankrupt ideology and the
people forwarding it have profoundly
mediocre Minds well it's not that it's
that there is no ideology
so what do you mean so I mean this is my
consistent position on what wokeness is
wokeness is the modern left liberal
culture formulated by social media
algorithms it is characterized by
cult-like adherence to Liberal social
Orthodoxy that's all it is thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time